الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الجيش
الروسي يركز هجماته بشكل كبير على محاور
بينها بخموت ولمان في دومباس وفي موقع
ريبار العسكري الروسي ان عناصر ان عناصر
فاجنر تمكنوا من عزل المدينه عن ضحيتها
الشماليه الغربيه بعد سيطرتهم على بلده
جديده للمتابعه ينضموا الينا من كراماتورس
مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي وفي دنياتك
الخاضعه لسيطره الانفصاليين معنا مراسل
الجزيره امين درغام ونبدا معك امين واخر
التطورات في يتعلق بالتقدم المسجل عند
محور باخت من قبل مقاتل فاقدر
[موسيقى]
هذا ما كانت مواقع روسيه من بينها موقع
ريبار العسكريه المتخصص قد اكدته صباح
اليوم بان قوات فاجنر بعد ان كانت قد
سيطرت على برخوفكا واتجهت الى ياجدني
المجاوره عزلت مدينه بخموت بالكامل عن
ضواحيها الشماليه الغربيه لكن المثير
والجديد في هذا المحور هو ما تناقلته
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه قبل قليل فقط حينما
اكدت على ان القوات الاوكرانيه فجرت سدا
قرب الضواحي الشماليه لمدينه بخمود فيما
يبدو انه محاوله لوقف تحرك قوات فاغنر
باتجاه الاحياء الشماليه للمدينه وقالت
بان مياه ذلك
تلك القناه المائيه وصلت الى منطقه ستوبكي
التي تبعد بنحو كيلومترين ونصف من هذه
القناه المائيه ولربما هذا سيشكل خلال
الساعات وربع مع الايام القليله المقبله
عائقا امام تقدم قوات بهذا الاتجاه ولا
هذا ولعل هذا ما يفسر ال سي لربما فتح
محورا اخر باتجاه الطريق الذي يربط بين
مدينتي بخموت وسلافيانس فيما يبدو انه
توسيع لمحور هذا التحرك العسكري لعزل ضخمه
بشكل كامل ايضا من بين التطورات الهامه هو
ما ايضا اكدته مواقع مؤيده لروسيا هنا في
دونيس قبل قليل بان القوات الروسيه وسعت
ايضا من هجماتها حول مدينه
القريبه من هناك والتي ظلت لربما اشهر
طويله
عصيه على القوات الروسيه حيث
تمركزت القوات الروسيه قرب من بلده
افديفكا دون ان تحرز اي تقدم منذ نحو
تقريبا عشره اشهر او اقل بقليل بعد ذلك
مدينه حيث نحن ما زالت تتعرض لقصف
بينه والاخرى السلطات هنا اكدت مقتله مدني
واحد وجرحى اخر في قصف تعرضت له مدينه
لا تبعد كثيرا عن دونيسكو وايضا شددت على
ان الاحياء الشرقيه الغربيه عفوا الشماليه
من دونياسك تحديدا كويبشكي وبتروسكي
وكيرفسكي كل هذه الاحياء تعرضت لقصف
بالمدفعيه الثقيله وصواريخ الجراد منذ
الليله الماضيه وحتى وقت قريب فقط تصلنا
بين الفينه والاخرى اصوات لهذه
الانفجارات التي تؤكد ايضا على تواصل
القصف في تلك المناطق عامر لا في فكره كيف
تعاملت السلطات الاوكرانيه مع هذه الانباء
عن عزل باخموت
تواصلت قبل قليل مع مصادر في الجيش
الاوكراني في بخموت قالوا لنا بان نعم
الوضع الاسوء والاخطر ربما للجيش
الاوكراني هو في المحور الشمالي لكن ليس
هناك اي نوع من العزل الخوف عند يتم تطويق
المدينه
الجيش الروسي تقدم من المحور الشمالي في
اتجاه الاحياء الشماليات سيطرت الجيش
الروسي وقوات فاجنر على مدينه بيرخفكا
وتقدمهم داخل مدينه داخل بلده ايضا يهدنا
الخطر منه الاقتراب من الاحياء الشماليه
لهذه المدينه وليس اكثر وهذا ما تقوم به
القوات الاوكرانيه دفع هذه القوات بعيدا
عن المدينه ولا يوجد اي نوع من التطويق في
هذه الاثناء اكدوا لنا بان الطرق كلها
سالكه ولا يوجد اي مشاكل لايصال كل ما
يحتاجونه الى داخل المدينه والقناعه هنا
ربما لدى الاوكرانيين بانه لم يتم
الانسحاب من هذه المدينه الا الجيش
الاوكراني بانه سيتم ستتم محاصرته داخلها
وبالتالي سينسحب الرئيس زيلينسكي قال في
اكثر من مناسبه لان نعم بخموت مهمه لكننا
لم ندافع عنها حتى اخر جندي وبالتالي
حينها فقط سيتم سحب القوات الاوكرانيه
الكثير من السياسيين والعسكريين تحدثوا عن
السبب التمسك الاوكرانيين بهذه المدينه
وهذا ما يفسر ربما الاستمات صح وصفه في
الدفاع عن هذه المدينه السبب ربما وكما
جاء ربما باكثر وضوحا على لسان رئيس
المخابرات الاوكراني الذي كان قد قال بان
التمسك والحفاظ على مخمود سيحمل منطقه
بشكل عام ماذا يقصد ويقصد بان القوات
الروسيه ذا سيطرت على لن تتوقف عند حدودها
وانما ستحاول التمدد والتمدد من مخمود
يعني الوصول هنا الى كروماتورس كالعاصمه
المؤقته لهذا الاقليه لهذه المقاطعه وايضا
الى سلافيانس ثاني اكبر المدن التي تسيطر
عليها اوكرانيا في مقاطعه دونيس وبالتالي
مهم جدا بهذه المدينه الامر الاخر هو ان
هناك خطوط دفاعيه معده مسبقا ويمكن من
خلالها مواجهه القوات الروسيه في هذه
المدينه قال رئيس المخابرات بان قدره
الجيش الاوكراني على تكبيد الجيش الروسي
خسائر كبيره متاحه جدا في هذه المدينه
وهذا ما نريده لماذا لان قوات النخبه
القوات المميزه لدى الجيش الروسي هي التي
دفع بها الى هناك وحتى القوات المميزه في
فاجنر وبالتالي تكبيد هذه القوات خسائر
كبيره سيجعل قوات الروسيه غير قادره على
القيام بربما بهجمات كبيره على مدن اخرى
مستقبلا اذا ما استمر تكبدها للخسائر
الكبيره على هذا المحور ميته من داخل
المدينه وبالتواصل مع
مصادرنا في الجيش الاوكراني كما ذكرت
المحور الشمالي هو الاخطر محاوله للتقدم
من المحور الجنوبي من الشرقي وفي المحور
الجنوبي هناك هجوم معاكس القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت من خلاله من دفع القوات
الروسيه بعيدا عن الطريق الرئيسي بين
شكرا جزيلا لك عمر لا في مراسلنا من
كرامات وشكرا لمراسلنا امين درغامي من
دنيا